Happy birthday!
It’s your day to enjoy however you want,
with lots of gifts and sweets.
And look - a little friend is here to help
you celebrate.
It’s the birthday monkey, and he has a song
to sing…
Dating back to the 1940s, SCP-983 is one of
the most harmless-looking objects in the SCP
Foundation’s possession.
It’s an old-fashioned mechanical monkey,
a common wind-up toy from the old days.
It’s dressed in a sharp little vest, and
holds a tiny bell and striking rod for making
music.
It seems to be a simple toy, the kind that
would annoy a tired parent as it plays its
little tune over and over, but nothing more.
But this is no ordinary wind-up toy.
SCP-983 is capable of sounds and even speech
that doesn’t seem to match up with its design,
and an investigation reveals it doesn’t
have any signs as to how it was constructed.
No screws, seams, or markings that would be
common on a toy, and no voice box or other
mechanical feature that would allow for speech.
But despite these oddities, it seems to be
a normal toy that can be handled safely and
played with.
On every day but one... that is.
Because SCP-983 has a secondary purpose, and
on one special day it has a gift for its handler.
It can be a gift of joy - or a gift of terror.
Nicknamed the Birthday Monkey, SCP-983 activates
when it is handled by someone within the twenty-four
hour period of their birthday.
It seems to be able to tell when this period
of time happens automatically, and as soon
as it becomes aware, a series of surprises
begin to surface for the lucky - or unlucky
- handler.
It all starts with a little leap.
As soon as SCP-983 becomes aware of the birthday
boy or girl, it’ll do a charming little
backflip.
It’ll then lift its bell and start singing
the same song - “A Ring Ding Ding Ding It’s
Your Birthday!”
To this day, the Foundation has not been able
to figure out exactly where this voice comes
from, and it follows this by ringing its bell.
The tone of the bell varies wildly - in ways
that the instrument should not be able to
create, ranging from low tones to painfully
high-pitched tones.
And that’s where the horror begins.
The Birthday Monkey doesn’t just want to
sing a song - it wants to play a game.
The song will repeat every three to four seconds,
marked by rings of the bell.
And for every ring of the bell, the birthday
boy or girl will age a year - continuing until
they die of old age, or win the game.
But how does one win the game before it’s
too late?
No one is sure, but studies of this strange
toy in action indicate that it involves singing
along - and timing it correctly.
It’s probably a little hard to do that while
aging to death in seconds, but no one said
SCPs play fair.
But in the event that someone actually does
manage to survive the Birthday Monkey’s
game, it has a prize for them.
When the sing-along is complete, SCP-983 will
let out an enthusiastic shout of “Birthday!”,
ring its bell, and drop a single gumdrop from
its bell.
But which gumdrop depends on just how well
the birthday victim did.
A perfect sing-along will result in a clear
candy that seems to glow.
If it’s a little less than perfect, the
candy won’t glow, but it’ll work the same
- and both candies have a very valuable property.
When eaten, the candy will immediately reverse
any age lost during the “game”.
But does the perfect score give another prize?
Studies of the rare glowing candy led the
Foundation to believe that it may also provide
a bonus effect, making the person who eats
it younger and giving them a longer lifespan
or better health.
But this is largely guesswork, because the
candy is produced so rarely and the effects
would only become clear after years or decades
of study.
But not all candies are to be eaten.
Many candies of different appearance and quality
have been produced.
All can be eaten safely - except the black
ones, which represent a failed sing-along.
The effects of this candy were discovered
the hard way - because the first time SCP-983
was activated, it was activated in the wild,
before the Foundation had secured it.
And everyone knows that an SCP in the wild
can be a terrible thing.
It was a local flea market, when the buyer
noticed the sharp-dressed little monkey.
The buyer, having a friend who loved monkeys,
thought this would be a perfect gift.
The seller was not as enthusiastic, and warned
the buyer that it shouldn’t be handled or
even seen by anyone on their birthday.
But even the seller didn’t really believe
this, saying that it might have just been
an old legend that had been passed down for
years.
It didn’t dissuade the buyer, and off the
monkey went to its new home.
SCP-983 was activated at an office party,
where the monkey was presented as a gift.
The guest of honor loved it at first - until
it started singing.
The staff noticed that as the monkey kept
singing, their co-worker became more and more
upset.
The monkey kept singing, and he started to
search for a way to turn it off - but there
was no button or any other way to deactivate
it.
And that’s when the coworkers noticed something
disturbing.
The honoree seemed to be getting weaker and
weaker, and there were even streaks of grey
appearing in his hair.
His skin was getting more wrinkled and weathered.
Soon his hair was entirely grey, and he simply
returned the monkey to where it was as it
continued to sing.
He seemed to give up, begged for someone to
turn it off, and waited to expire.
By the time the Foundation arrived on scene,
it was already too late.
There was nothing left of the birthday boy
but a desiccated, skeletal corpse.
The monkey had been able to sing at least
thirty more verses, and no one had truly understood
what was going on.
They reacted with confusion and inaction,
unable to contain the monkey’s dangerous
game.
Even the Foundation didn’t understand SCP-983
at first, so they let the object continue
singing until the body degraded into a simple
skeleton.
That’s when the monkey exclaimed its finishing
phrase and released a single black gumdrop.
While no one ate the gumdrop, the Foundation
observed that it seemed to hypnotize people
around it, as if it was compelling them to
do something.
What is lurking within the black gumdrops
- and do they want to be consumed?
The birthday monkey was taken into SCP custody,
and it became clear that it was harmless to
everyone for 364 days of the year.
The foundation wanted to understand more about
this odd toy, so they fell back on their best
resource for testing - D-class personnel,
who got the chance to show off their singing
skills with much higher stakes than your average
round of karaoke.
Most of the tests were routine, with controlled
activations showing how to deactivate the
monkey - or providing up-close studies of
its devastating effects.
But one test hinted that this specimen could
be more dangerous than thought.
Few people volunteer for testing duty at the
SCP Foundation, but that wasn’t the case
for one now-classified subject.
Her birthday was approaching, and she surprisingly
volunteered for the test that could only be
done on your birthday.
She had an oddly upbeat attitude and seemed
oddly excited about her birthday.
The test was approved, and she was given limited
information.
She was given the monkey as a wrapped gift,
told it would sing, and encouraged to sing
along for a video.
But her reaction indicated she might know
more than expected.
As soon as the gift was unwrapped, the SCP
began singing.
After missing the first verse, the subject
picked up the words and started singing along
- not just competently, but perfectly and
enthusiastically.
Soon enough, she started aging rapidly, but
didn’t seem distressed by this at all.
She maintained her high level of enthusiasm,
even as the monkey sang for over forty verses
and aged her over forty years.
She seemed unaware of these drastic changes,
and never missed a beat of the song until
the monkey issued its finishing exclamation.
And now, it was time for her prize.
The gumdrop that fell from the bell was a
new one, completely white and almost shockingly
bright.
It glowed, and the subject was immediately
enchanted by it.
Even the attending scientists and staff couldn’t
help but comment on how impressive it was.
The subject was allowed to consume it to see
its effects, and was monitored for an hour
afterward.
When nothing unusual happened besides the
reversal of the aging, the subject was excused
to return to her quarters.
And that’s when things took a shocking turn.
In an effect never seen before, the subject
suddenly exploded with a brilliant burst of
white light.
Whatever this light was, it was strong enough
to knock out all the cameras in the vicinity.
Everyone in her presence was temporarily blinded,
with it taking five minutes for their eyesight
to return.
No long-term ill effects were shown, but the
staff that entered the room after the blast
noticed that an odd glow remained in the room.
And that wasn’t the only odd thing.
The test subject was nowhere to be found - and
has never been seen again.
The Foundation is on high alert for this test
subject, but she seems to be staying below
the radar - if she’s even human at all anymore.
While there is no physical sign of her, the
Foundation has observed odd patterns of electromagnetic
activity in the area and is following reports
of light fixtures needing to be replaced.
It was clear that SCP-983 was much more unpredictable
than expected.
While still classified as safe, the Foundation
is keeping SCP-983 under tighter lock and
key these days.
All technicians who handle it are carefully
vetted to ensure they are nowhere near their
birthday.
In case of accidental exposure, the Foundation
has prepared emergency kits with detailed
instructions for how to complete the Birthday
Monkey’s deadly sing-along game.
But as with all things, the Foundation is
prepared for anything.
In the event of a failure, the remains will
be disposed of by vetted staff.
Any candies produced are to be taken into
custody by the Foundation and studied for
unusual properties, but are not to be consumed
without full containment procedures and approval
from senior staff.
The only exception is D-class testing - but
even in those cases, one rule remains intact.
No one is ever to consume the black candies.
And caution is encouraged around the Birthday
Monkey - lest you wind up in a sing-along
for your life.
For more on an ordinary object with unique
properties, check out “SCP-978 - Desire
Camera”, or watch “SCP-342 - A Ticket
to Ride” for another particularly tricky
trap.